the most
condescending and mean
was a
it was a professor at the time but she
was a cast director for that particular
day and moment and for the particular
event
she said
it's not up to me to say it and i'm
quoting her exactly it's not up to me to
say it
but the reason why you will never play
the leading ladies is because of your
weight
she said it exactly that way
and that was a shock to me and i think i
started shaking a little bit
because
in my heart
i knew i do plus size modeling so i
didn't mind my weight i never minded my
weight
i never felt like i was
um
uncomfortable in my body because i
always it's my motto and i every girl i
would ever help i would say dress for
your size not for the body that you want
to have
so i always feel like i dress like a
lady and i feel comfortable in my
clothes and i feel comfortable in my
body so when somebody said that to me
all of a sudden
it took all my female women issues
and put them in the way of my career
and that was the first time something
became an obstacle in my career
because no matter what my age is no
matter where i'm coming from i worked so
hard to be where i'm at that no matter
what people say to me about packages and
characters and types and stereotypes
doesn't get in my way of pursuing what i
want
but when somebody lifted the way of the
of my the issue of my weight
to get in the way of a character that i
wanted
that
hurt
more than i could ever think of it never
got in my way again after that and to
think that she went ahead and gave me
the leading lady
is what even that bothered me more
she went ahead and gave me the living
lady that day when she was casting
but she said that to me the day of
and i was like you're contradicting
yourself and you hurt me for no reason
so
but yeah
that was a challenge that was a huge
challenge that day i cried
i guess the negative thing is just
basically
not fitting the description i mean like
i hope one day you know
people will be more open to being like
oh a filipino girl a filipino or any
type of um nationality can play
a um a ghetto girl
i mean i know something like this
but i mean
i wish hopefully one day like i said
they're open to just having different
types of people play different types of
roles and not just keep it so
you know
so secluded and everything it's
oftentimes about
being able to do martial arts
and
being able to speak with an accent you
know i've been asked that
those two things by agents by casting
directors
um
a lot you know and
and i've gotten
you know again i i don't i don't i think
part of it is is minority actors you
know heightened sensitivity but
it's also the insensitivity of other
people i've been told so many times
you're like oh my god you you remind me
of and i'm thinking like okay you know
who who can it be
you know
de niro you know dicaprio who and though
you ron remind me of jet li of jackie
chan you know
and who knows how much of that is
sincere you know but but a lot of it is
is there's so many
there's so many pieces in that
conversation
lack of representation and also the lack
of
people's kind of willingness to see
beyond beyond race
so those you know i there are a lot of
things that people have
said that that kind of would strike me
in a
in a way that that is
you know frustrating you know i haven't
been you know it's been a long time
since i've been approached with
something really blatantly racist
um i don't know if it's
who i am or i feel like i carry myself
myself in such a way that people either
don't want to have that conversation
with me or or i i'm lucky enough to
surround myself with wonderful people or
whatever
but
i think in the last
five six years you know
i don't face as much
um
but it it it certainly
is represented in the number of
auditions that i i miss out on
um
the roles i don't get to
you know play i definitely think that
that is
another form of
you know insult you know that may not
say verbally but
you know what i heard was that sia
you need to learn how to be a ghetto
girl because those are the worlds that
you're probably going to go for when
they just look at you
because a casting director is not going
to hear your voice until you open up so
you need to learn how to do that and for
me that was insulting because i was like
ghetto does that mean all black people
just go for ghetto rolls
i don't understand that
so that was that hurt me that really did
hurt me
and
that's when i decided that you know i
need to there needs to be a change in
this industry i mean number one it's a
struggle for women in this industry
period but let alone women of color in
this industry i mean look the asians
haven't even made it in yet so it's like
you know as a black person there needs
to be
a change in there so
that's that was the most harmful thing
one time i did uh i did go to an
audition and uh they told me i would sit
there
and they told me that i wasn't uh
marketable
yeah so i i and i was wondering why and
this was back in the nine
in the early 2000s when i when i was
doing uh auditioning and so forth you
look great hey but you're just not
marketable well stereotype more because
of my height they asked me if i could
lose a bunch of weight so i would be
more model type i guess
so i could play a model because i'm too
fat i guess to be a model and i'm not
yeah too fat to be model i'm not fat
enough to be like an obese like you know
curvy person so i was on set once um for
this little web series and they asked me
if i could you know for the next episode
if i could lose weight and i was just
like no no i can't i'm sorry um just
because i don't want to stoop down to
that level where people can tell me what
to do and i have to adjust myself so i
will be worth something i want to you
know stay the way i am and be true to
myself there was this one incident when
i went into agency
um the receptionist she was so rude to
literally everybody i mean she would
yell at the the miners like if you don't
have your parent in here you can't come
in you know the people coming in for
auditions you know once again she was
more so doing it towards the minorities
i was noticing like i said i'm a very
observant young man and i was just
sitting i was standing in line waiting
to you know approach the receptionist
myself
i approached her you know politely kind
ma'am i please you know just sign in
trade cards well for my appointment and
she just throws it like huh and she
tells me to go sit in the lobby versus
everyone else who's actually going into
a waiting area of the agency and once
again not thinking anything negative
about it just okay i go into the lobby
to fill out my paperwork another black
guy comes sitting into the in the lobby
and i'm noticing but when the caucasians
you know signed in for their interviews
they're being sent into the waiting room
and i just thought that was so
interesting so that did kind of bothered
me inside so when the agent came out to
like have me you know get ready for my
interview i decided not to go through
with the process and i told the um agent
you know i don't feel comfortable with
doing it the agent was like very adamant
like what's the issue what's wrong with
the car as well we actually need your
look for something and i'm just like you
know i don't want to mention it i didn't
tell on the receptionist i wouldn't i
wasn't trying to be be the bad advocate
try to have anyone lose their job
because it's not going to get anywhere
in life you know i could easily like
well your reception has been so rude but
like i said i try not to put that
negative energy out there so i just told
the agent i couldn't do the interview i
left and i felt good inside because i
still had my dignity and you know i felt
very disrespected and honestly like my
mother was telling me if
she's pretty sure the agency does know
about this receptionist and her
character so honestly if they have her
like
literally greeting people how do you
think the agency is as a whole so
with that being said i kind of just i
feel good about that decision i made to
just actually walk away from which could
have been a probably major big
just
good thing in my life but i walked away
from it you know because i i did feel
you know disrespected and i did feel
like i was being
looked down because of you know
my ethnicity my race my you know